[Music]
the president spent his morning in
Washington's National Cathedral
attending a memorial service for a
former Defense secretary
he would have known then that he faced
an investigation into classified
documents found in his private office
and his garage at home
the U.S attorney general announced an
independent investigator will look at
whether a sitting president has broken
the law I signed an order appointing
Robert Herr a special counsel for the
matter I've just described
the document authorizes him to
investigate whether any person or entity
violated the law in connection with this
matter I like to drive I used to think I
was a pretty good driver Joe Biden's
Corvette featured in one of his campaign
ads in the last election so did his
garage now in the spotlight and you feel
like you're in complete control speaking
before the announcement of an
investigation he talked security
invoking the vehicle classified material
next to your Corvette what were you
thinking
let me uh look I'm going to get a chance
to speak on all this God willing soon
but as I said earlier this week
people and by the way my Corvette's in a
lock garage okay so it's not like you're
sitting on the street Biden's supporters
highlight a difference in circumstances
between him and his predecessor Donald
Trump had several hundred classified
documents in his Florida home and he
resisted their return Biden they say had
a few and they were immediately handed
over
before Democrats draw a distinction
Republicans draw parallel here's an
individual that was so concerned about
President Trump's documents locked in
behind and now we find it just as a vice
president keeping it for years out in
the open in different locations here in
Washington the president's teams say the
documents in his possession were
inadvertently misplaced that will be one
question for the special counsel another
will concern dates documents were first
discovered on the 2nd of November last
year that was just days before the
midterm elections why it's taken this
long to become public may not be Central
to any prosecution it will be to the
political Fallout
James Matthews Sky News Washington